-Performing "Air Quotes" from
their album "Liberation 2,"
with a little help from
Amani and Diani,
give it up for
Talib Kweli and Madlib!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Turn
artificial intelligence ♪
♪ The art of genocide, blatantly
irreverent ♪
♪ European settlements ♪
♪ Motive, secular,
action is testament ♪
♪ The question of ♪
♪ Who better than who ♪
♪ Stay constant as the change
in my pocket ♪
♪ Cracked smiles evident ♪
♪ Tactile etiquette ♪
♪ There ain't no regimen ♪
♪ The Third World light
let us in ♪
♪ My people like, "Let us out" ♪
♪ No matter what this hotel,
this place ain't checkin' out ♪
♪♪
-♪ Time is money,
so we take it in blood ♪
♪ I did my dirt and got it
straight from the mud ♪
♪ Stop going to clubs
because these cats
be so thick with the love
♪ Air quotes, nah,
I ain't makin' this up ♪
♪ They fake as...♪
♪ I used to hit up
all the spots,
but I would stay in the cut ♪
♪ Watchin' the girls drink for
free, promoters makin' a fuss ♪
♪ While the hip-hop police
is out here waitin' for us ♪
♪ Steady scopin', hopin' to take
us all away in some cuffs ♪
♪ I'm outta this
so-called "artist,"
the definition of toxic ♪
♪ Tryna advertise the ignorance,
mission accomplished ♪
♪ I promise it's so much more
than just makin' a product ♪
♪ I'm an artist,
you're a creator of content ♪
♪ There's a difference ♪
♪ Can't see the trees
for the forest,
they stuck in them boxes ♪
♪ Complaining about
how predatory the game is,
do nothing to stop it ♪
♪ I get reckless
with my abandonment
like I jumped in the mosh pit ♪
♪ And learned how to put
some trust in the process ♪
♪ Mobsters make them an offer,
they can't refuse
and then start
raiding the coffers ♪
♪ They get confused,
trying to choose between
the gods and the monsters ♪
♪ It's a lie ♪
♪ Though they tried to put
hip-hop in a coffin ♪
♪ We ain't the one
that pulled the trigger,
but, yo,
you still an accomplice ♪
♪ Rappers cowards 'cause
they scared to be conscious ♪
♪ Only care about they pockets ♪
♪ This is not
a popularity contest ♪
♪ The truth is often unpopular ♪
♪ So when I'm droppin' these
jewels, it's not for the views ♪
♪ It's for the topple of
the conquerors ♪
♪ This ain't the Suicide Squad ♪
♪ I ain't talkin' about
Starfish ♪
♪ Ready to risk it all
and sell they soul
for a profit ♪
♪ Yellin' "banzai," kamikaze
pilot stuck in the cockpit ♪
♪ I no longer trust the optics ♪
♪ The photos be doctored ♪
♪ Post up with live bloggers,
The Shade Rooms,
and the Bossips ♪
♪ These imposters forgot what
the Bible say about gossip ♪
♪ James 3:16,
that slander's demonic ♪
♪ Protect your spirit
from these heathens,
stop readin' that garbage ♪
Come on.
-♪ Time is money,
so we take it in blood ♪
♪ I did my dirt and got it
straight from the mud ♪
♪ Stop going to clubs
because these cats
be so thick with the love
♪ Air quotes, nah,
I ain't makin' this up ♪
♪ They fake as...♪
♪ I used to hit up
all the spots,
but I would stay in the cut ♪
♪ Watchin' the girls drink for
free, promoters makin' a fuss ♪
♪ While the hip-hop police
is out here waitin' for us ♪
♪ Steady scopin', hopin' to take
us all away in some cuffs ♪
-♪ You listenin' to green,
our money clean
and a lot of it ♪
♪ Writing my own story,
give them something
to plot against ♪
♪ I need my own fence,
all owned by my lone end ♪
♪ I give em hope, yeah,
just know that I'm focused ♪
♪ Givin' em air quotes 'cause
these words finna transcend ♪
♪ Just like my hair comb,
you gonna be facin'
these dead ends ♪
♪ I put my hair up just in case
a bozo wanna try me ♪
♪ And real know real,
but the clothes don't deny me ♪
♪ I got a book from Nkiru ♪
♪ Knowledge makes
the cops fear you ♪
♪ Did my crime, did my time ♪
♪ But he's still in
my rear-view ♪
♪ If I don't kill you,
it's your conscious,
so, really,
how could I fear you? ♪
♪ You're tasteless
and disappointing ♪
♪ I ain't givin' no ear to air ♪
♪ I'm an heiress ♪
♪ I'm the one they compare to ♪
♪ I'm fruit, you pork,
you chewed, you soft ♪
-♪ Dog food ♪
♪ Awful ♪
-♪ Give em a jaw full ♪
♪ If you "F"
with the withdrawal,
it ain't cordial ♪
♪ I come from Kweli,
so I'm really an animal ♪
♪ Like the safari,
I could corpse you ♪
♪ I could bring you up
and endorse you ♪
-♪ One in a million, baby ♪
-♪ The feelin' is crazy ♪
♪ I head towards the light
'cause the industry's shady ♪
♪ I'm throwin' vibes,
one of a kind ♪
♪ Startin' to feel like Brady ♪
♪ Pops already made
a couple mill ♪
♪ So it would be hard to
enslave me ♪
-I really raised a GOAT,
didn't I?
-Baaaa!
-♪ Hey, hey ♪
-♪ Time is money,
so we take it in blood ♪
♪ I did my dirt and got it
straight from the mud ♪
♪ Stop going to clubs
because these cats
be so thick with the love
♪ Air quotes, nah,
I ain't makin' this up ♪
♪ They fake as...♪
♪ I used to hit up
all the spots,
but I would stay in the cut ♪
♪ Watchin' the girls drink for
free, promoters makin' a fuss ♪
♪ While the hip-hop police
is out here waitin' for us ♪
♪ Steady scopin', hopin' to take
us all away in some cuffs ♪
-"Liberation 2,"
you gonna respect the greens.
[ Cheers and applause ]